hello and welcome to Khan Academy live
SAT class my name is Eric I'm an SAT
tutor and one of the SAT experts here at
Khan Academy this is class number two of
three that we have planned for the SAT
over the next few weeks and I'm very
excited to be covering SAT reading today
Before we jump into SAT reading only
give you a preview of what we're going
to cover today and next week let's take
a look
so last week we covered SAT mass in our
first class and if you missed that class
don't worry we recorded it and you can
find it on our YouTube channel so go
ahead and check that out if you're
interested and today like I mentioned
we're going to cover SAT reading and
then the following week we'll cover SAT
writing and all of these classes will be
at the same time so Thursday though I'll
be on Thursdays at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific so these are all the classes
that we'll have planned and for today
let's take a look at what we'll cover
for SAT reading so for today's class the
first 25 minutes I'll spend giving some
instruction and doing some practice
problems together specifically I'm going
to introduce a strategy called rephrase
and predict which is a more proactive
approach that you can use for SAT
reading questions that I found really
helpful and that many students find
helpful to try next I'll cover word in
words and context problems and command
of evidence problems as well and we'll
do some practice problems together then
in the next ten minutes I will answer
some student questions and so at that
point you'll have a chance to add
comments to in YouTube and I'll try and
answer as many questions as I can at the
time that I have I'll give out the Khan
Academy badge and all of that and then
in the last 25 minutes you'll practice
what you've learned on Khan Academy and
just like last class work we have a
number of Khan Academy and College Board
experts available to help you
while you have questions so unlike last
class there after the instructor
and QA I'll sign off and you'll just
head the Khan Academy to practice you
won't need to come back to YouTube this
time around so you'll spend 35 minutes
on YouTube and then in the next 25
minutes practice do reading problems and
we'll be there to help via one-on-one
chat so let's take a look at what we're
going to cover and get started so why
are we talking about proactive reading
strategies today well let me pose a few
questions and let me know if the anyb
sound familiar if you've ever been in
this kind of situation before so have
you ever read the answer choices and
thought well all of these look good and
you know you're kind of stuck there or
maybe you get the answer get the
question down to two choices but then
end up picking the wrong one or you're
always 50/50 and not sure which one to
pick or maybe you're like I was when I
first started on the SAT practicing for
the SAT reading and maybe you run out of
time on the SAT reading section well
that's why we're chatting about the
rephrase and predict strategy so this
strategy is one that I found that was
really helpful for me and helpful for a
number of students and so I'd recommend
giving it a try certainly not the only
way to approach SAT reading questions
but it can be really helpful once you
get the hang of it when you are
approaching SAT reading questions so
this strategy really focuses on coming
up with your own answer to reading
questions before you look at the answer
choices so this is the most important
word before and there are really two
parts so this first part involved it's
called the rephrase portion and this
part involves reading the question but
covering the answer choices and this is
really important so that you don't
distract yourself with the answer
choices up front and then if possible
rephrase the question into how what or
why question and this can really help
simplify the question to put it in your
own words and can just make sure that
that you understand the question before
you move on
the next step in this strategy is to
predict and so you would start by
reviewing the relevant parts of the
passage so go back and reread a little
bit before a little bit after where you
need to and then based on that predict
the answer to the question in your own
words and so if the question is asking
the author's purpose in paragraph two is
you actually say in your own words well
I think it was to introduce amphibians
to as a as a reason there's a you know
as a relevant population for this
biological study so you would say
something in your own words to answer
the question then and only then would
you uncover the answer choices and then
start crossing out the choices that
don't match your prediction and select
the choice that best matches and so
instead of a more different approach of
reading the question looking at the
answer choices and then evaluating one
by one you come up with your own
prediction first and then that really
can help when you do finally look at the
answer choices and it can help you hone
in on the ones that match your
prediction and are supported by the
passage and eliminate the ones that
might look plausible but once you have
that prediction in your mind of well I
think the answer is this amphibian thing
it's easier to do that matching and to
hone in on the right question so let's
take a look at what this looks like for
a practice problem now just to make it a
little more tangible than real so step
one if you're watching from home is to
take your hand right hand left hand
whichever one and cover up the answer
choices a through D so go ahead and
cover up those answer choices and now
we'll do the rephrase part of that
strategy so as used in line three event
most nearly means and so this is a you
know more straightforward question but
it is just essentially we could rephrase
it - what does event mean and now if I
had the passage I could I would go back
to the passage read a little bit around
the word bent gather some context clues
and then say my prediction
so the second part of the strategy was
that vents meant gap and so I'd write
down my prediction or just say it in my
head and then and only then so you can
lift up your hand now would I look at
the answer choices and at that point
with gap in mind it's a bit easier to
eliminate some of the answer choices
that don't match and narrow it down to
the ones that do so for example gap you
know doesn't fit passage as well
doesn't fit outlet as well and then I'm
found an opening and crack and then in
the real SAT I would go into the reading
passage gather some context clues and
see what see what I'm finding there so
that's an example of some of the how
this rephrase and predict strategy looks
for a standalone sample problem and
later in class we're going to apply this
strategy in a real SAT reading passage
with a few questions just so you get
used to it but before we do that I want
to cover words in context and command of
evidence problems which are two common
problems that you'll see in the SAT
reading
so words in context questions what are
these exactly so these problems measure
your understanding of the meaning and
use of words and phrases in the context
of passages and this word context is the
most important part and so these
questions don't ask you to define words
that you know you might know the meaning
of words in day-to-day life like
determination but what makes these
questions unique is that the context of
the passage is crucial and so you want
to look a little bit before and after
and around the word so that you can
gather the surrounding words ideas and
circumstances to one's to pick up on how
the author is using the word in the
passage and what it means and so there
are two specific types of words and
contexts questions and the first one is
interpreting words and phrases in
context so this asks these questions ask
you what a word or phrase means as used
in the passage and so that's very much
like the sample problem we did around
you know the word bent has used in line
three most nearly means and so probably
familiar with these
the next type asks you how the office
choice of words affects the passage and
affects the meaning tone and style so if
this first question type is more of a
what question the second question type
is more of a purpose or impact is one
helpful way of thinking about it so
we'll take a look at these words and
context problems later in class but this
is a should give you a good overview of
the types of words and context questions
you might see on the SAT and on the
reading section and also in the writing
section so let's keep going out to
command of evidence so command of
evidence questions are designed to see
whether you understand how an author
uses evidence to support a claim or
argument or point that they're making
and this is a skill that's tested on the
SAT because it's really crucial in
college in the workforce you know once
you graduate or in day-to-day life and
so it really has very applicable to
creating the arguments defending
arguments evaluating them and on the SAT
how will they show up well there are
three types of evidence questions that
you'll see and so the first one asks you
to determine the best type of evidence
so it will ask you what textual evidence
provides the best support or they the
other type of question here will show up
in pairs where it will ask you you know
what is the main points of paragraph 1
and then the second question will ask
you what evidence that supports your
answer to your to the first question now
the second type of question and there
the evidence section is will ask you to
interpret data in graphics of different
kinds and it will allows you to look at
the graphic understand it and how it
relates to the passage in any claim the
author may be making now if I would have
here would be to break down the graph
piece by piece so rather than trying to
understand it all at once
ask your
just one simple question at a time so
that you build up your understanding
from the ground up and so you could ask
what is the title and what is it telling
me you could ask about the axes next
into the axes and units you might look
at the key and all of these questions
will help you build to the point where
you can state in your own words this
graph is showing me the distribution of
fir trees around California now the
third and final type of evidence
question asks you how the an argument
uses or it doesn't use specific pieces
of evidence so those are things like
facts figures quotations and how that
influences the author's claims or
arguments that they're making so I there
was a lot of information to take in
upfront but let's now apply what we've
discussed so far on the rephrase and
predict strategy words in context
questions and a command of evidence
questions within a real SAT passage so
let's get some practice together before
you head off the Khan Academy to
practice yourself let me zoom out a
little bit here so before I start in
before we start going through this
passage I just want to share that how we
go through the passage today might be a
little bit different from how you would
do this if you were by yourself at home
and it's mainly it's just because I'm on
computer and so it's harder it's a just
a little hard for me to show you all of
the passage at once and so just for
today as we walk through it we'll go
through this a few paragraphs at a time
and bounce back and forth between the
questions but how you would do that at
home might look a little bit different
okay
so let's take a look let's go ahead and
read the passage just up to this point
here and then we'll pause so let's go
ahead and do that this passage is
exerted from Hasley kill'em a hug a day
keeps the doctor away
okay Scientific American okay so
cause of study during my final semester
of undergrad I made two signs that read
feeling stressed about exams have a free
hug then I recruited a friend and we
stood in the entrance of the campus
library held up the signs and waited
passers-by had one of two reactions
either they quickly look down at their
phones they're not really shuffled by or
their faces lit up as they embraced us
most people are enthusiastic some
explained you made my day or thank you I
needed this one left into my arms nearly
toppling me over after two hours of warm
interactions my friend and I couldn't
believe how energized and happy we felt
okay so let me go through that again and
just mark up a few important things so
feeling stressed about exam so free hug
and they had warm interactions and then
at the end they were feeling pretty
energized and happy so then this is
seems like just a story about how at the
end of this person's undergrad career
okay so it's read the next paragraph now
a study published earlier this month
suggests that in addition to making us
feel connected to others all those hugs
may have prevented us from getting sick
okay so that seems important and this is
the topic sentence of the paragraph so
worth paying a little more attention to
at first this pub defining public seems
counterintuitive and not to mention
bizarre you might think like I did that
hugging hundreds of strangers hugging
strangers would increase your exposure
to germs and therefore the likelihood of
falling ill okay but we've got a butt
here so but words contrast words are
very important and often signal a shift
in the passage so but the new research
out of Carnegie Mellon indicates that
feeling connected especially through
physical touch protect us from stress
induced sickness okay so this research
adds to a large amount of evidence for
the positive influence of social support
on health okay so just so to confirm
that I understand this passage
we've got topic sentence that said
feeling connected to others seems have
these health benefits
and hugging a lot of people rather than
exposing you to germs actually according
to the Carnegie Mellon study offered
some protection against stress induced
sickness okay okay so I think I
understand that and what you'll notice
as I was reading the passage was that I
was pretty actively writing and
underlining and making sure that I
understood what I was reading as I went
and so there's an active reading article
that we have on Khan Academy that I
would be great to check out but that's
how you can read and make sure you
understand along the way to save
yourself time so you your aren't you
aren't rereading as much as you go along
so we have the passage now let's look at
the first question so here we're going
to use the rephrase and critic strategy
that and we mentioned so again take that
take your left hand or your right hand
whichever non-dominant hand you have and
go ahead and cover up a through D and
now we're going to look at the question
so the first paragraph serves mainly to
so we're just looking up until this part
everything above this part and if I
rephrase this this is just what is the
purpose of the first paragraph okay so I
don't need to write that down since
it'll take me some time so what is the
purpose of the first paragraph well
let's take a look at the first paragraph
and probably a little bit of context
from the second as well and that will
inform my prediction for what I think
the answer is so when I was reading this
passage earlier this seems like a the
author's story about something he did in
undergrad about making signs and
mentioned how positive these these Hutus
hugging experience was and then in the
next paragraph we've got the study and
the impact of hugs and we get a little
more scientific here and so the purpose
the first paragraph there's mainly to or
the purpose of the first paragraph my
prediction here is going to be that
there was a story and then if we look at
the structure here we have the story
here and then we have the study here so
that's kind of how I'm thinking about
its story
that leads into the study and so that's
my prediction and as you can see it
doesn't have to be super sophisticated
and complex in fact if you have a good
understanding of the passage the
prediction is often pretty simple in a
few words is all that you need and so
now I can uncover the answer choices a
through D and take a look at which one
matches my prediction of you know the
the author told this use the first
paragraph as a story as a way of
introducing and giving background for
this study so let's take a look at the
first one provide background information
necessary to understand the scientific
study so that is not completely off from
what I mentioned but not exactly what I
said either so I'll leave that in and
then introduce the scientific study
through a personal anecdote okay so
that's actually very close to my
prediction since an anecdote is a story
and I mentioned this introduce piece so
that seems like the top candidate so far
but let's take a look at these other
ones so show that not all scientific
experiments need to be conducted in a
laboratory well we're not talking in the
passage about all scientific experiments
and there's no mention of a laboratory
in the passage so I can go ahead and
cross that one out and then the last one
to try the author's experience as the
subject of the scientific study so the
first paragraph is more of a story and
the author actually doesn't mention that
it was a scientific study it was just
more something that they did in the last
semester so the scientific study will
eliminate this and so B is really the
best choice that matches my prediction
which is based on the information that I
had in the passage so that's an example
of how rephrase and predict is used in
practice it's and can take some getting
used to but once you practice a little
bit more you'll get faster and faster at
that and at once you have the prediction
going through the answer choices will be
a lot faster now the other thing I'll
point out is that as I was going through
the answer choices you might have seen
me cross off certain parts of answer
choices and
that was because the right answer will
be completely right and supported by the
passage and if there is a part of an
answer choice that feels offered isn't
supported by the passage that's enough
for me to cross it off and so that just
helps me eliminate answer choices a
little bit faster and is another thing
you can try so let's take a look at some
of the other questions and keep on going
so let's take a look and the second
paragraph the author implies the study
shows hugs to be so now we're talking
about this paragraph second paragraph
here often plies that the study shows
hugs to be so this is I can rephrase
this to be study shows hugs to be to be
question mark okay and again I'm not
looking at the answer choices yet since
not will automatically that will
automatically influence and I'll start
influenced my thinking and all started
thinking well maybe it's a maybe it's
the before but before I have for my own
opinion I don't want to do that so let's
take a look back at the second paragraph
and a and look for the study and what
the author is implying about that so
study published earlier suggests that
hugs make us feel connected and prevent
us from getting sick and prevent us from
getting sick and then here's the study
here so new research out of Carnegie
Mellon shows a feeling connected
especially through physical touch
protects us from stress induced sickness
so that is pretty positive so hug good
is a I'm going to take away there and so
then my prediction for what the author
is saying about implies that the study
shows about hug is that hugs are good
for health good for health and have
these health benefits or have these you
know protection will help protect us
from sickness or protection
sickness from sickness and now with that
prediction I can go ahead and uncover
the answer choices and look through a
through D so let's take a look a says
it's the hugs or the only proven method
of preventing sickness so only proven
method I makes makes that not correct
because the study says that there are
some benefits of hugs but certainly
doesn't claim that if the only proven
methods and doesn't match kind of it
this my prediction either so let's keep
going less successful than social
support and protecting people from colds
and other illness illnesses so this in
this case they're making an interesting
comparison here about less successful
than social support and that's really
not something that's mentioned in the
second paragraph and again doesn't match
my prediction based on the paragraph so
this less successful than social support
there's no comparison that's being made
in that paragraph so we go ahead and
cross that out and then we have not
conclusively effective at helping people
maintain good health so this actually
the tone of this is hugs are so so like
they're not sure about hugs but this was
we have hugs good here we know hugs are
good even if we didn't read the passage
so that not conclusively effective is
the opposite of what the author is
actually implying and so deep in one of
several ways to guard against some
illnesses well here was not part of my
prediction so protect from illness good
for health and so therefore my answer is
C so this was now an example of a
command of evidence problem and how the
rephrase and verdict strategy can be
used in that context but this is a
two-parter so we're not done yet let's
head back in and pinpoint the evidence
that matches and supports our answer
so which choice provides the best
evidence for the answer to the previous
question so in this case let's take a
look we've got again so we're looking
for the best evidence here let's go back
and look at the the passage here and
again we're not looking at the answer
choices and so why did I choose D is
essentially what what the passage is
saying and what evidence from the
passage supports that and so this is
about the study showing hugs and so can
hone in here on the tugs good section
and the study is mentioned here about
Carnegie Mellon the Carnegie Mellon
study about physical touch protecting us
from stress-induced illness so that's a
great thing and so I think that that's
really where where I made my decision
there and so then I can uncover the
answer choices and looks like answer
choice C is that answer and so just for
a completion sake I'll make sure to look
through some of these other ones just to
walk through but that matches exactly
what I was thinking and my prediction
about the Carnegie Mellon study so line
12 through 14 a study section so a study
published earlier suggest that in
addition to making a seal connected all
these types may be prevented us from
getting fixed so that one feels more
like commentary and oh I actually forgot
I posted this down here so we can look
down here too so that one is more of
commentary so that one's up and then 16
to 18 you might think like I did that
hugging hundreds of strangers would
increase your exposure that again is
more commentary and isn't providing
evidence and then D is 21 to 23 this
research as to a large amount of
evidence here and again that is not as
strong as the evidence presented here
that we're citing from Carnegie Mellon
so that one is out as well okay so now
we've done some command of evidence now
let's take a look at a words in context
question and that'll be the last
practice problem we do together before
we move on to a few other things
so and let's take a look at the next
paragraph here so it looks like we're
looking here now from here to here so
social support can broadly be defined as
the perception of meaningful
relationships that serve as
psychological as a psychological
resource during tough times more
specifically this means emotional
support such as expressions of
compassion and may include access to
information or other assistance the
researchers measured social support by
giving out a questionnaire in which
participants rated different statements
then they conducted interviews every
night for two weeks to find out how
often participants experienced conflict
with others and how often they received
hugs
finally the researchers infected
participants with a common cold virus
and observed what happened that part
seems questionable I don't know about
the ethics of doing that last part but
the the fact is that this paragraph then
is saying social support what that means
and it looks like it's emotional support
and expressions of compassion
information and assistance and then this
would be how they conducted the rest of
the experiment
okay so then in line twenty-seven
expressions most nearly mean so what
does expressions mean and so more
specifically this means emotional
supports such as expressions of
compassion and may include access to
information or other assistance okay so
I've taken into consideration the
context and it seems like in this
context it's expressions of compassion
could also be stated as acts of
compassion or kindness and so these are
some more physical behaviors is going to
be my prediction so then let's take a
look at what matches my prediction so
demonstration yeah that could be
demonstrations or an acts of kindness
seems pretty close declarations of
compassion that's more words but I've
got acts here so I don't think that one
fits as well we've got revelations so
that's more that means
something like discoveries and we're not
discovering kindness here so that's out
then looks of compassion also doesn't
quite fit since I'm all about acts of
compassion and so demonstrations of
compassion really is what fits best so
this was the last practice problem that
we'll do together and if you want to
re-watch any of what we've gone through
we'll send out the recording again but
now it's uh now it's time to do some I'm
going to answer a few questions and so
if you have any questions go ahead and
put them into the YouTube comments now
and then I'll answer as many as I can
before we head over to Khan Academy to
practice what we clicked so take a
minute to do that as I get set up here
okay so we got a few questions from
students here so let me take a look
first question are there deducted points
for incorrect answers on the SAT so
answer to that is no there is no
guessing penalty on the SAT on any of
the sections and so that means if you're
not sure how the right answer for a
question you should always guess and so
that goes for multiple choice or free
response in the math section is there
you should always guess since there is
no guessing penalty
let's see another question we got was is
are the SAT practice tests on par with a
real test like if I score 1,300 on the
practice test would I expect to score
that on the SAT well assuming you're
talking about the practice tests on
official SAT practice on Khan Academy
the those practice tests are official
SAT tests released by College Board and
are an accurate reflection of what you
can expect on the real SAT so if you
find yourself consistently scoring say
in the 1250 to 1300 range that is a
pretty good indication of what you'll
get and what you might find on the real
test date but the only thing I would say
is there on the real test days there
might be a few factors that aren't at
play during practice tests like nerves
or you know how well you slept or what
you ate that day so
it is a pretty good indication but it
might not be exactly perfect we got a
question about general advice on how to
manage time well the resource I'd direct
you to there is there too are a handful
of articles on the Khan Academy and our
tips and strategy section that have tips
for how you can manage your time on math
reading and writing and so it really
give that a thorough read through and it
really has everything that I would tell
you to do anyway and I think we'll try
and post that link in the comments as
well but there are things like working
through you know some of the simpler
problems first since all SAT questions
are worth the same number of point going
through the easier and medium questions
so that you have ample time for those
before you go to the harder questions is
one one way you can do it but really
check out those articles for is the best
device that we have on that we had a
question if your prediction doesn't
match the answers does that mean you
read it wrong so that's a great question
so say you had a prediction that the
word meant gap in then it didn't match
anything in the in the answer choices
what I would encourage you to do then is
yes to go back into the passage and make
sure you had you considered all of the
context around the passage and make sure
you understand that paragraphs well
enough that you can restate what the
author is saying and what the purpose of
that paragraph is in your own words and
if you can state it in your own words
that is really a good check to see if
you understood the author's point and
the argument or statement that they were
making and so if you your prediction
doesn't match in that case yeah I would
go back to the passage and make sure you
understood what the author was saying
and then give that prediction another go
another way you could approach it is to
just look at what the passage says and
the evidence there so the right answer
in SAT reading questions will have
textual evidence to support it and so
you you can work backwards in a little
bit too
look at the pathogen see okay what what
evidence do I have to support one of
these answer choices
another question should I read the
passage first or read the questions
first so that one a there are a lot of
different opinions on this and I would
say it really comes down to how you've
practiced and what you found works well
so some people will lead through and
scan the questions just so that they can
mark out in the passage okay I've got a
question at line 7 and pushing that line
53 and then I need to notice a shift in
tone somewhere and so that for some
students they like to look at what
they're going to be asked in so that
they know where to pay more attention to
in the passage other students they want
to just focus for other students a
different approach of reading the whole
passage really understanding and
understanding each paragraphs and
doctors argument and claims and then
looking at the questions is easier so
that they're just focusing on
understanding and then going into the
question so I would really say practice
try both see which one works best for
you and go with that
I just wouldn't if you're close to the
your test they don't change things up at
the last minute
okay so we have another good question if
you're forced to skip a question or gift
and have enough time to go back should
you go back to it at the end of the
passage problem set or at the end of the
reading portion so I would definitely
say at the end of the passage problem
set so say you have questions 1 through
11 on reading passage and you skip
number 9 to like I don't know it could
be either these once you get to question
11 and you finished all the questions on
that passage leave visit question 9 at
that point because it'll be easier for
your brain to stay within the mode of
that passage whereas if you wait till
the end of the passage
you then have to remind yourself okay
what was this passage about and what was
question 9 asking so it'll just take you
longer to do that so we're coming up a
little bit on time now and so I'll
unfortunately all the questions I can
cover for now but I'll cover more
questions next time and for now I want
to show you a few pointers for about SAT
practicing for the SAT on Khan Academy
the badge one-on-one chat and all of
that good stuff so let's let's take a
look so like I mentioned at the
beginning we have people waiting to help
you if you run into any questions and
chat with you one on one so but a common
question we get is what if I don't see
the one-on-one chat box on Khan Academy
well one thing I will point out is that
the one-on-one chat is only available on
the SAT part so make sure your web
address looks something like Khan
Academy org slash mission slash SAT and
if you're not on a URL that looks like
that then that's why Olark is not the
one-on-one chat is not showing up the
other thing you can try is to try and
refresh the page as well now when you
head over to Khan Academy eyes the first
thing I'd recommend you do is to explore
a bit and then do some practice problems
so while we have those wonderful folks
are volunteering their time to help the
first the best thing you can do is start
by doing some practice problems yourself
and then if you get stuck we reach out
in just a bit we're also going to share
the badge Lincoln so that'll show up in
the comments and for that you will sign
into your Khan Academy account and then
your badge will show up in the top right
corner oh this is no longer right but
there will be a notification icon that
you'll see there and so we'll post the
badge there and so now if you're
familiar with official SAT practice on
Khan Academy go ahead and head over
there now and sign into your Khan
Academy account start practicing and if
you get stuck reach out to one of our
amazing people who are who are here to
help you today if you're brand new to
official SAT practice I'm going to do a
quick walkthrough of some of the key
parts just to get you started so this is
official SAT practice on Khan Academy
and so you'll see this is the homepage
and if I wanted to practice I just head
over here and click practice and you'll
see that I have math reading and writing
and
save portions as well and for today
you'll see that you can practice any
reading topic here or if you wanted to
go to writing and language you can
practice anything here as well now if
you want to refresher on a topic that
you don't see here I really recommend
you go up here to the search bar and
type up a search for say a quadratic
equation right that's one thing you can
do and then if you have general
questions about the SAT the format
strategies you can use so time
management for example these are too
great are the articles that I mentioned
before I would head here to go through
and get answers to those questions let's
take a look and I think that's most of
what I was going to cover so go ahead
and head over and then the last thing
I'll call out is this is where you'll
see that chat box and so you can just
type in here ask a question and we'll
get back to you and reply as quickly as
we can so that's all I have for you
today I on YouTube and so now it's time
to head over to Khan Academy practice
what you've learned if you get stuck or
have any questions we're here to help
for now that's all we have for today
but I hope to see you next Thursday at 7
p.m. Eastern 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific for our last and final class on
SAT writing thanks so much
and I hope to see you next time